theresa consume tacos y autos de juguete
la tabla muestra la utilidad marginal de
theresa de los tacos y los autos de
juguete cuál es su utilidad marginal
total al comprar 3 autos de juguete
pausa en el vídeo y traten de responder
a esta pregunta vamos a resolverlo
juntos primero vamos a asegurarnos de
comprender lo que nos dicen aquí esto
dice que el primer taco que consume
teresa recibe 8 unidades de utilidad
marginal del segundo taco recibe un poco
menos de utilidad marginal quizás a su
antojo de tacos se satisfizo al comer el
primer taco del tercer taco recibe aún
menos utilidad marginal y así
sucesivamente por cada taco adicional
con respecto a los juguetes vemos que
theresa obtiene mayor utilidad marginal
del primer juguete obtiene 10 unidades
del segundo juguete obtiene una utilidad
marginal un poco menor y vemos que esta
utilidad marginal disminuye con cada
juguete adicional consumido por teresa
respondamos la primera pregunta cuál es
su utilidad marginal total al comprar 3
autos de juguete del primer juguete
theresa obtiene 10
desde utilidad marginal del segundo
juguete obtiene 8 unidades y la utilidad
marginal del tercer juguete es de 6 por
lo que la utilidad total es de 10 + 8 6
que es igual a 24 unidades de utilidad
marginal ahora veamos la pregunta 2 el
ingreso semanal de theresa es de 11
pesos el precio de un taco es de 2 pesos
y el precio de un auto de juguete es de
un peso qué cantidad de tacos y autos de
juguete maximizar a la utilidad de
teresa si ella gasta todo su ingreso
semanal en tacos y autos de juguete
explica tu respuesta usando el análisis
marginal de nuevo pausa en el vídeo y
traten de responder a esta pregunta el
punto clave aquí es que una vez que
conocemos el precio de un taco y el
precio de un juguete y conocemos la
utilidad marginal por cada taco o
juguete adicional podemos hacer que el
dinero rinda más podemos calcular la
utilidad marginal por peso de cada taco
o juguete adicional vamos a explicarlo
primero
theresa maximizará su utilidad marginal
por
cuando haga compras en el margen su
próxima compra incremental aquí ponemos
la utilidad marginal de cara a taco por
peso y aquí abajo ponemos la utilidad
marginal de cada juguete por peso vamos
a señalizar bien estos renglones y vamos
a calcular esto para el primero para el
segundo el tercero el cuarto el quinto y
el sexto analicemos primero los tacos
los tacos cuestan dos pesos del primer
taco se obtienen ocho unidades de
utilidad marginal lo que es cuatro
unidades marginales por peso 8 dividido
entre 2 aquí son 4 unidades por peso
para el segundo taco ella obtiene 7
unidades pero le costó 2 pesos en 7
unidades entre 2 pesos nos da 3.5
unidades 6 entre 2 es 35 dividido entre
dos es 2.5 4 dividido entre 2 es 2 y 3
dividido entre 2 es 1.5 unidades de
utilidad marginal por peso ahora
analicemos los juguetes cada juguete
cuesta un peso ella obtiene 10
desde utilidad marginal por el primer
juguete que le costó un peso así que son
10 unidades entre un peso aquí es 8
simplemente dividimos entre 1 cada uno
de estos aquí es 6 aquí 4 aquí 3 y aquí
2 ahora que tenemos toda la información
que necesitamos vamos a hacer un poco
más de espacio vamos a pensar en cuál
sería la combinación más sensata para
que teresa maximiza la utilidad de sus
11 pesos semanales si comparamos el
primer juguete contra el primer taco el
primer juguete tiene mayor utilidad
marginal por peso comparado con el
primer taco así que primero compra un
juguete y luego se pregunta si a
continuación deberá comprar un taco u
otro juguete pero si vemos la utilidad
marginal por peso del segundo juguete
está sigue siendo mayor que la del
primer taco así que ella compra el
segundo juguete luego piensa que
comprará a continuación hasta el momento
sólo ha gastado 2 pesos por lo que aún
queda mucho por gastar y se pregunta si
comprará otro juguete o un taco pero
vemos que todavía obtiene mayor utilidad
marginal por peso
del tercer juguete que del primer taco
así que compra el tercer juguete y
apenas ha gastado tres pesos y ella de
nuevo piensa cómo gastará el dinero que
le queda y ahora está indiferente entre
comprar un cuarto juguete o el primer
taco la utilidad marginal por peso es la
misma para ambos quizá ella decide
comprar un cuarto juguete y después de
eso entonces compra el primer taco
finalmente ahora veamos cuánto ha
gastado hasta el momento gastó cuatro
pesos en juguetes y dos pesos en el taco
el orden puede verse algo así y ahora la
utilidad marginal por peso por taco
adicional es mayor que la del quinto
juguete por lo que compra otro taco
cuánto dinero ha gastado hasta el
momento dos tacos cuestan cuatro pesos
más cuatro pesos por cuatro juguetes así
que aún le quedan tres pesos para gastar
ahora su utilidad marginal es neutral
entre el tercer taco adicional y el
quinto juguete
ella está indiferente entre ambos por lo
que compra uno de cada uno podría
comprar primero este y luego este o
hacerlo en el orden contrario cuanto ha
gastado hasta el momento
gastó 5 pesos en juguetes y 6 pesos en
tacos por lo que ella ya gastó sus 11
pesos así que para responder la pregunta
escribimos que ella debe comprar 5
juguetes y 3 tacos con base en esta
estrategia de maximizar su utilidad
marginal por peso para cada compra
incremental con esto respondimos todas
las preguntas determinamos la cantidad
de tacos y juguetes para maximizar su
utilidad si ella gasta todo su ingreso
semanal y explicamos el porqué usando el
análisis marginal nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo